When we look at poor
smallholder farmers across the world,
and particularly in my country, India,
we often think that what they need
is access to better tools,
education, government support,
markets and so on.
Yes, they need all that.
But what they really need
is a reliable and regular income
to live with dignity.
A dependable income,
even if it is as small
as 100 dollars a month,
is essential for them
to stay out of poverty.
Today, their incomes
are in and out of poverty,
which is extremely painful.
Growing up in South India,
I could not overlook
what poverty did to our farmers.
I was about 17 years old when one day,
I saw a farmer in my village
sitting next to a farm stream
and eating something from the ground.
Something did not seem right.
I walked up to him
to see what was going on.
I was shocked to see him eat mud.
Mud.
Brown, soft mud from the stream.
I was afraid he might die.
I yelled at him.
"What is this stupid mud-eating business?"
He looked at me helplessly and said,
"I'm a farmer, my crops failed;
my stomach doesn't know
that my pocket is empty."
I walked away quite helplessly.
That night, I shared this
with my grandfather.
He was a remarkable man, very clever.
He was a part of the Indian
freedom struggle
under the leadership of Mahatma Gandhi.
Unlike me, he wasn't surprised at all.
He knew of people
who added rice starch to mud
to calm their hunger.
And he told me something profound.
If you see a person walking
on the road without footwear,
it is important to understand
the root cause:
that the person doesn't have enough money
to probably buy the footwear.
I finished my college,
started working with a big company,
but that incident kept coming back to me.
Why are smallholder farmers
in such abject poverty?
What causes them to be so desperate,
and why is it that,
even in 21st-century India,
one farmer dies by suicide
every 51 minutes?
My cofounders and I spent about six months
traveling across India,
meeting hundreds of farmers
to listen to them.
It became clear that climate risk
is the root cause
that causes farming to be
unpredictable and unviable.
Farmers who make
reasonable money in one season
can fail miserably in the next.
And farmers who could grow crops
earlier in summers
no longer get to grow crops in summers.
Heat is so much more.
The wells are drying up,
every year, there are new varieties
of pests and diseases.
Farmers told us that this is all
because of because of God.
I said, "What?"
"This is all because of God."
God is the one who caused it,
God is the only one who can solve it.
God, in that context,
I did not see as a sign of hope.
I read it as a sign of helplessness.
We heard from the farmers.
They knew the problem,
but they could not use
these two words: "climate risk."
So we got together a team of engineers,
scientists, designers
from about six countries,
to cocreate a solution with our farmers,
which is quite unconventional.
And the solution is “greenhouse-in-a-box.”
We call it "Kheyti Rakshak."
It’s a micro-greenhouse.
It's a beautiful greenhouse
which sits in a small portion
of the farmer's land.
It's easy to build, a small structure,
covered with netting on all sides,
which cuts off heat,
prevents bugs and saves water.
We can't cool the entire
planet in one day,
but we definitely can create a climate
for a small portion of a farmer’s land
to be suitable for farming.
From our first experiences
of growing vegetables --
staple vegetables like tomatoes,
cabbage, cucumbers --
we observed that greenhouses
can increase yields up to seven times
and use 90 percent less water.
All this was too good to be true.
All these things
are so difficult to happen,
so farmers couldn't believe it,
unless they actually saw it in action.
So to make this happen,
we had to have the courage
to reimagine agriculture --
reimagine agriculture
for smallholder farmers.
After all, this is not to grow tomatoes
in an industrial setting in Alaska
in winters.
It is to grow tomatoes
for a smallholder farmer,
by a smallholder farmer,
in sizzling hot Indian summers.
So this greenhouse had to be small enough
to fit in a portion of their land,
easy enough for them to use
and cheap enough for them to buy.
One of the biggest challenges
that we could overcome in the process
is financing.
Thanks to our financing partners,
today, this greenhouse
is available with financing
which is fast enough and cheap enough.
The greenhouse costs about 1,000 dollars.
Farmers pay a down payment
of about 100 dollars,
and the rest is financed through a loan.
And this life-changing asset
adds and extra 100 dollars of profit,
on average, to a household,
month on month.
This is a good double
of what they otherwise make.
Marginal, five-ten percent increases
in the incomes of smallholder farmers
cannot move the needle forward much,
because the baseline is way too low.
We need a significant
jump in their income,
and that income has to be
reliable and dependable.
To ensure that farmers succeed,
we also provide quality seeds, nutrition,
training and advisory
leveraging mobile technology.
We rolled out the solution,
after quite a few tests with farmers,
about three years ago,
and we are marching towards
2,000 farmers in this year
and looking at 100,000 farmers
over the next five years.
Hopefully, every smallholder
farmer in my lifetime.
(Applause)
The best technologies in agriculture
can reach the smallest of the farmers
if we do two things well:
listen to the farmer with curiosity,
empathy and compassion,
and keep smallholder farmers,
particularly women farmers,
at the center of the design,
and build solutions.
Then, we can cocreate
mini solutions like Kheyti Rakshak,
which bring dignity, hope and stability
to the lives of the farmers.
In this big fight against climate change,
we all have to remember that we should
take our smallholder farmers along;
it is our collective responsibility.
India is a home for about 100 million
smallholder farmers.
I dream of a day
when "smallholder farmer" becomes
synonymous with a happy farmer,
and being forced to eat mud
should never be a feature again, anywhere.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)